guys so I made my own version of getaway
while I was driving home from the
screening tonight
please enjoy give me back my wife
where's my wife where's my give me back
my wife Selena Gomez what are you doing
in here
get away stars ethan hawke and Selena
Gomez and this movie is what I call a
gimmick movie it's the kind of movie
where the entire plot rests around this
thing that has to happen and what that
is is that Ethan Hawke can't leave that
car he can't do anything he has to do
everything that this voice tells him
this voice on the phone has his wife
never reasons I won't divulge Selena
Gomez gets into the car and now Ethan
Hawke and Selena Gomez have to go on
this giant night filled with car chases
explosions accidents and lots and lots
of shaky camerawork I really like Ethan
Hawke as an actor but here he doesn't
really have much to do and I'll explain
why this movie purely exists to show a
whole bunch of car chases and that's
really all it has to offer
but unfortunately the director behind
the film felt that it would be most
entertaining to use footage from like
$10 webcams and lots of shaky camerawork
and really quick cuts split-second shots
where you can't really tell what's going
on because apparently that is the new
trend nowadays where every single thing
has to be 10 billion shots of the same
thing or you can't see it and it looks
horrible basically the entire movie is a
no plot strung together quick thing
let's have a whole bunch of cars flip
over you know nothing about Ethan
Hawke's character you know nothing about
Selena Gomez's character the only things
you learn are what is needed to propel
the story which sometimes can work if
you have a director behind the wheel so
that's a nice little pun that I did not
mean to make who understands how to tell
an interesting movie that isn't just
some gimmick film that comes off as a
big gigantic car chase one after another
like I don't say the movie starts with
these and Hawk just getting in the car
and going and there it is we're in the
movie now and that could be entertaining
because there isn't that time to breathe
so to speak in movies which I've said in
the past is a good thing when it movie
doesn't give you that time to breathe
but here you just need some kind of meat
you need something behind the story
besides he took my wife and I'm going to
do everything he says which includes
crashing every car I see because
apparently he wants me to do that Selena
Gomez in the movie I really don't
understand what
in this film it just feels like I don't
hate her or anything it just just
doesn't fit in with this movie you have
all these actors who are trying and then
they're Selena Gomez is also trying but
you can't not see Selena Gomez she's not
playing a character it's just there
Selena Gomez in the car and it just
doesn't work there is however an
extremely surprising absolutely
fantastic scene at the end of the film
that I don't even understand where it
came from it's like this sustained two
minute long shot of a car chase it was
fantastic it's one of the coolest car
chase moments I have ever seen I don't
even know what happened it's almost like
Steven Spielberg came in was like I'm
gonna direct this one scene okay okay
thanks bye cuz the entire rest of the
movie is this shaky unclear HD webcam
footage of car chases that doesn't look
cool or interesting in any way then all
of a sudden you know the movie they're
just like hey let's do this incredible
tank is gonna blow your mind
everything else is completely
unimpressive unfortunately I was hoping
getaway would be fun but it just really
is a by-the-numbers type of films it
seems like it should be straight to DVD
that has impressive stunt work because
you can tell all these drivers are doing
things it just doesn't look good but for
the most part getaway is just a really
really subpar chase movie with virtually
no plot some okay acting and a really
great shot towards the end but nothing
else of much importance I'm gonna give
get away a c-minus I wouldn't suggest
seeing this one I think you can skip it
for sure
as always guys thanks very much for
watching and if you liked this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]